au moins les écocentres des sacs et des
risques associés à ça mais je pense
qu'on peut sérieusement on était content
parce que on sent que les enfants ils
ont besoin de ça
[Musique]
moi mon fils est en deuxième année et
donc le s'est rendu quoi la moitié de
son parcours scolaire qui qui s'est fait
dans ce contexte là donc je vais
pression c'est un peu sa nouvelle norme
à lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame car mike o bonjour nous serons je
n'y ai vu notre intégration peut pas
encore le réflexe voilà merci nous
accueillit les renier on va aller se
promener dans cette école loeb vous
allez m'expliquer comment dans la vie de
tous les jours vous êtes adapté ça a été
une révolution permanente oui vraiment
annonce
[Musique]
hickory dans des premiers cercles bien
deuxième c'est incroyable essai c'est
une grande école
c'est une très grande école l'oscd
récrite deuxième c'est pendant les
vacances je vous est ce que vous avez
craint les vacances de noël avez vous
craint que ça n'ouvre pas oui c'est ce
que vous pensez en fait l'annoncé
ministre mavs des du premier ministre
m'a surprise mais on était heureux en
fait l'enfant du personnel était content
de revenir
pour nous c'est comme retrouver un
semblant de normalité
on vient à l'école ya des enfants il ya
de la vie donc vous êtes d'accord avec
monsieur legault quand il dit depuis le
début en fait depuis début quand il dit
on va tout faire pour garder nos écoles
ouvertes là ça va être la dernière chose
qu'on va faire on est obligé de le faire
dans le ccd fermé on est d'accord on est
d'accord
tout ce qu'on sait tous que le personnel
veut c'est que par même temps et doivent
se sentir plus en sécurité
moi mon rôle est de m'assurer que
l'école soit sécuritaire
autant pour mes élèves que pour mon
personnel mais en même temps faut aussi
qu'elle soit agréable
donc on essaie de huy de faire
l'équilibré entre ces deux là il faut
pas que les contraintes tellement
nombreuses que ça que ça gage processus
faites vos que les contraintes soient
viables viable et vivable
c'est le cas et c'est le cas pour
l'instant ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous
outils style un peu un peu pour nos
élèves de 5 et 6 oui par la journée avec
le masque on souhaite que ça soit pas
comme ça jusqu'à la fin de l'année
l'on comprend qu'on a un fou a donné ce
qu'on dit aux élèves comme je vous
disais c'est le prix à payer pour être à
l'école donc no 5 et 6 le comprennent et
l'accès puis ça se passe bien là mais
bon quand même reconnaître ces gens là
donne
mais là la main à la pâte de tout ce
qu'il en donne beaucoup et on leur en
demande beaucoup on en manque beaucoup
on leur en donne vous mais ils sont au
rendez vous donc vraiment de quoi être
fiers de donner raison les masques
pourquoi parce qu'ils veulent le fasse
nos classes d'accueil premier cycle ok
les parents ou les enfants peuvent
décider de porter hockey et non pas à le
porter d'accord c'est bien
bonjour je m'appelle
[Musique]
tassé lors avec toi laisse aussi
l'horaire toilettes on a vu la pause
pipi
voici un bel exemple de réorganisation
oui on dit à tout le monde pendant 20
minutes c'est tout de suite j'avais
envie ou en fait tout dans une école et
n'est pas simple donc quand quand on les
mesure où il fallait qu'à une
distanciation entre les groupes
mais comme on n'a que deux grands blocs
sanitaires je pouvais pas m'attendre à
ce que mes trente groupes descendent en
même temps même dix groupes
parce que quand arrive et les
récréations c'est ce qui arrive est donc
là on s'est dit on va faire un horaire
pause pipi le matin et l'après midi est
prévu séparés nous nos dîners en trois
groupes pour que tant la cour d'école
les élèves et chacun leur zone pour que
débute la soit respectée donc à trente
deux groupes fallu penser à trois dîners
différents pour aller à l'extérieur
trois temps différent quand une
horlogerie du fonctionne bien c'est oui
mais il fallu penser alors de geler la
mettre en place
[Musique]
totalement hors c'est tellement que même
si c'est votre cas doit chaque jour le
mas des pauses obligatoires
on fera pas semblant l'homme et non ma
petite et la plus de bonjour alors
viviane au niveau du travail académique
parce que les enseignants vont rapporte
que du retard
je disais que tu bail en fait les
enseignants ce que ce que j'entends de
leur part c'est que ils veulent
s'assurer eux que laurent lors enfin
leurs élèves arrivent à la fin de
l'année à la même place que les autres
europe aurait été consacrée quand même
une pression chez eux ont le on l'a
vraiment senti avec le retour des fêtes
où on était à distance enfin pas combien
de temps cela allait durer l'exposé des
questions mais comment je vais y arriver
avez vous confiance qu'on veut rattraper
le retard sur autant lac
moi je pense qu'on va le rattraper mais
peut-être sur une couple d'années là
parce qu'on parle quand même de trois
mois je dis pas que des indics routard
c'est catastrophique on n'y arrivera pas
mais probablement que l'année prochaine
les profs qui recevront la corde qui ont
remonté devra aussi s'ajuster un pool
est ce que les services aux élèves en
difficulté on vous parlait beaucoup de
soin avant la crise est ce que on arrive
à les donner quand est-ce qu'on suit les
élèves à ce qu'il y en a qui t'ont à ric
rac bain
en fait nous on suit nos élèves vont de
réajuster nos services en conséquence
l'offre de services par exemple en
deuxième année on veut mettre un peu
d'ordre pédagogique et lorsqu'on sait
que la rue arabe et les roches aux ondes
et les ressources faut savoir les
redistribuer à des écoles qui en ont
payé une pénurie en adaptation scolaire
vous dira tout pédagogie nous jusqu'à
présent on est chanceux
bonne journée je remédie l'aération dani
clos oui comme je suis je vois que
d'ouvrir ben ça se passe bien ici pour
l'ensemble de l'école s'est lassé de la
ventilation naturelle donc on ouvre les
fenêtres
donc depuis depuis le début la rend même
le début des classes là des consignes
ont été données aux enseignants les
fenêtres le plus possible doivent rester
ouvertes on avait déjà prévu quand
arrive l'hiver bat faudra laisser un
filet ouvrir quand les enfants sont pas
là pas besoin dans votre avis de
purificateurs d'air pour l'instant bah
écoutez moi je pas une spécialiste du
domaine je suis directrice d'école j'ai
fait un bac à ventilation
mais selon ce qu'on entend bain pour
l'instant ça serait pas nécessaire avec
les fenêtres bonjour
[Musique]
bonjour à l'usm alger bonjour on ce
choix de quoi pour la rentrée prochaine
l'automne un retour à une normalité une
école s'est ouvert sur son menu on ne
vous coûte par amis qui viennent de
façon bénévole lire aux élèves des
activités avec les enseignants notent
tout ça est tombée les neuf mois la
bibliothèque
donc tout ça ça enlève à la richesse de
l'expérience de l'école je pense autant
pour les parents que pour les
enseignants que pour les élèves
merci beaucoup de cette petite visite
dans votre vie quotidienne vous en est
bien sorti quand on voit leur eau il est
vraiment mais j'ai vraiment je vais le
signer est l'unique et pourtant jamais
c'est bon mais tenait le coup mais merci
beaucoup au revoir merci dire
[Musique]